can you make the case that the January
6th storming of the US Capitol is the
big deal and can you make the case that
it is not a big deal
I think the case is overwhelming that it
was a big deal and I opened the book
with this before going back to the end
of the Civil War because I think it
echoes that moment
um you had a group of people who
um literally tried to stop
the peaceful transfer of power
and were intending and there's
overwhelming evidence of this if they
had caught the vice president or the
Speaker of the House
to do bodily harm to them or to kidnap
them so this was a coup d'etat that is a
definition of a coup d'etat when you try
to capture and prevent elected officials
from doing their job that's a huge deal
that had happened before in our country
in States I talk about this in Louisiana
in Tennessee and places like that after
the Civil War but it never happened in
the capital that's a huge deal that is
if I might say that's like third what we
would think of as third world behavior
in our society and no offense to those
from other parts of the world I'm just
trying to make a point is how we see
that as happening somewhere else not
here that's a big [__] deal
uh the case that is not a big deal
I guess the case to make there is that
they didn't succeed
the case that is not a big deal is not
that their intentions were not bad I I
don't see how you can Define defend
their intentions the cases uh that the
case there's not a big deal so they're a
bunch of clowns
and uh yeah they broke in uh but in the
end once they got in there they didn't
know what to do which is true
and so you know I think a professional
couplotter would say these were the
amateurs
and that they had no real chance of
succeeding because once they got into
the capital they had no plan what to do
next what are they going to do you know
steal stapler from Nancy Pelosi's office
they didn't seem to have a plan and what
ended up happening they they left the
building would that that would be the
case that's not a big deal because their
intention was not to overthrow their
attention was to protest because if the
intention was to overthrow would be much
more organized I think the evidence is
pretty overwhelming that they intended
to to stop they were there to stop the
certification of the election they were
there to prevent Donald Trump from
having to leave office they just didn't
have a good plan this was the Keystone
Cops
so you're saying there is some POS like
statistically some possibility that this
would have
succeeded at halting the basic process
of democracy you could imagine a
scenario where it might have if they had
gotten lucky sure if they had if they
had caught the vice president
but what could have if they caught the
vice president they couldn't go on and
certify then he has to be there don't
you think that would resolve itself
through police action and so on my
question is how much how much is this
individual Hooligans
and how much of this is a gigantic
movement that's challenging the very
fabric well it's not a gigantic movement
but it was a small coup d'etat that
could have actually made the transition
much more difficult was there a scenario
where Donald Trump stayed in office
legitimately no but was there a scenario
where they created a great deal of chaos
that further undermine our democracy
actually yes here's how it would happen
right they capture Pence right they
either kidnap him and try to Ransom him
or they which is what they were trying
to do with the Michigan governor
governor Whitmer or they kill him and
then Donald Trump says okay well there's
no vice president so you can't certify
the Senate would choose someone else to
be vice president but Donald Trump says
no that's not legitimate I think it's
possible Donald Trump would say
something like that absolutely
I disagree with you he said that morning
that Penn should not certify he said
that morning but there's a difference
between sort of Twitter rhetoric no no
he said it at a rally sure rally
rhetoric and there is a threshold it
feels like a big leap he asked people
around him in the Oval Office how he
could make that happen he tried to get a
new person appointed attorney general
who would do that he tried to find legal
justification for it I I think the
evidence is overwhelming that Trump was
supportive of efforts after
the election didn't go the way he wanted
to keep him in office
and and whether that's legally
actionable and whether one thinks that
means he's a bad president or not isn't
a matter of opinion but facts are facts
yeah I just wonder if it's possible for
him to have stayed president in this in
this kind of context and he seems like
ahita just like you said elections can
even be violent uh they're they're
heated people are very upset when Donald
Trump won the presidency in 2016 I was
in Cambridge Massachusetts
uh the amount of anger
uh I was just get the energy I was
getting from people I mean that I if if
there was any way to channel that anger
I think people would be in trouble but
let's but let's anger yeah I agree with
that and that is right and elections are
violent as I said but this is different
this this is the person in the office of
the presidency using the power of the
presidency to try to stay in office to
imperil people's lives to distort our
government on a scale we had not seen
before and and these are not opinions of
mine we have the documentary evidence we
have the testimony from people about
this we can differ over what you think
of his presidency as a whole
we can differ over whether you think he
should be held legally responsible those
are matters of opinion but the facts are
he sat on January 6th watched it on TV
did not send ever
ever did he ever send any protection for
Congress that is his job
and throughout asked continued to ask
how this could the certification could
be prevented to you that's not
incompetence that's malevolence
absolutely
if I watch my children
getting harmed and I don't do something
about it I'm watching it and in fact I
take action that tries to help those who
are doing the harm you would not just
say I'm an incompetent president you
would apparent you would say it was a
negligent parent and you'd call parental
support to take away my children
I was troubled by the way the Press
covered it that they politicized the
crap out of that
um
and not not just the Press but also
Congress itself it just seemed like
impeachment and all this that just
seemed to be a kind of circus that
wasn't interested in in democracy or uh
non-partisanship
I don't so it's very difficult for me to
see the situation in with clear eyes
because it's been colored by the Press I
got it's very difficult for me to know
what is even true
members of Congress
including our members of Congress from
our district and others right
their lives were threatened
they were traumatized
I have a lot of students at least a
dozen who are staff members
more than half for republicans
part of what traumatized them
was that the president did not do his
job to not protect them yes as a child
would be traumatized not only if harmed
by someone but if Mom and Dad don't do
everything they can one of the things
that makes people feel safe is they know
their parents they know their personal
Authority can't always keep them safe
but they want to know the person's
always trying I agree with you that
they're listen I'm a I'm somebody that
believes in this kind of idea of family
especially people I work with that that
to me is a high ideal to protect but
that's a little bit different it's his
job that's a little bit different than
protecting democracy those are two
different things protecting the your
employees and protecting democracy is an
ideal no you could say he didn't protect
either but I think the criticism that he
didn't protect the employees is one
thing but the employees in this case are
the ones carrying out democracy so it's
like saying the general who doesn't
protect his soldiers is maybe not
protecting his employees he's also not
protecting the war effort right it is
his that the people we're talking about
the people who are actually doing the
work of democracy at that moment the
most basic function of democracy which
is certifying votes
and their lives with I I I'm telling you
I had I had students one who works for
Senator Romney for example who spent
hours in a closet
hearing people outside looking on her
phone when is the president sending
people to protect us so we can do our
job and she was not happy with the way
the election turned out but she was
there to do her job because she believes
in democracy to serve as the Senate and
the Senate's rule what should have
Donald Trump done without turning him
into a different human being he should
have immediately
it the just as we were watching things
get breached the moment they had that
the members of the house and the senate
had to evacuate their respective
Chambers he should have immediately gone
on TV and Twitter and every space he
could and tell his supporters to leave
and say what he never said
this is Un-American what you're doing
this is unacceptable we never use those
words this is Un-American this is
unacceptable I am completely against
anyone storming the capital like this go
home now please or you can use his own
language but tell him to leave yeah and
immediately as soon as we know he was
watching for hours and we have testimony
from his own daughter from Ivanka saying
she tried time and again to get him to
say something earlier on and he didn't
he watched it
he can still criticize
all the politicians he can criticize
everyone he wants but he should have
told him to leave all you should do in
that moment is basic a protecting
democracy protecting the capital Leaf
tell them to leave and do everything he
can to find any kind of force he can
give to go protect the capital
I wonder how difficult it is to lose a
presidential election
it's happened so many times we know I
understand that but it's uh
especially when like what what is it you
know uh 80 million people vote for you
or like some like millions and millions
and millions of people vote for you it's
crazy it's crazy this democracy thing is
crazy George H.W bush yeah won a war in
the Middle East right he had 90 approval
rating and then a year later lost the
election to someone Bill Clinton he
thought had none of the experience he
had someone didn't have he believed
didn't have the right moral character
and Bush did everything he could to help
the next president get started well and
they became good friends yeah George W
bush
if didn't love Obama
that's considered one of the smoothest
transitions George W bush ordered every
single person in his administration to
do everything they could to help the new
admittent that's that's what a leader
does